today on a special edition of Brian Ross
investigates Fox News under fire a court
ruling expected any day now on a lawsuit
brought against Fox News and its
coverage of the pandemic oh what's
bludgeon Trump with this new cloaks this
is again a very narrow issue is coated
19 a hoax it is certainly not the best
way to expose false it used to allow all
all statements to flourish we're joined
by the top lawyer for the New York Times
David macro and the editor-in-chief of
meaty id8 McLaughlin Fox News and the
First Amendment Plus who's watching the
hen house in the Trump administration
for inspectors general now fired by the
president a former Inspector General for
the Bush administration joins us to warn
of the consequent this is having a
chilling effect no doubt
Bob the inspectors general who remain in
it likely will have a chilling effect
also on those who might contemplate
becoming inspectors Channel and your
questions about covered 19 and the law
your job your home your rights your
wedding we really need the funds please
tell me where to turn from the law and
crime Network this is a special covered
19 edition of Brian Ross investigates
thank you for joining us and welcome to
our viewers at Facebook live and YouTube
lives I'm joined today by Rhonda
Schwartz my colleague at law on crime
and the executive producer of this
program and Rhonda we expect a ruling
sometime later this week from a judge in
Washington State Brian McDonald in a
lawsuit whether it can proceed against
Fox News which is accused of a campaign
of deception and dishonesty that's
coverage of the pandemic that's right
Brian a small consumer group known as
wash light it's the Washington League
for increased transparency and Essex
brought a lawsuit against Fox News in
the state of Washington for giving out
misleading information they say that
could be endangering Public Health and
they sued as a consumer safety lawsuit
and this is this is a ruling that we're
waiting to hear the case was heard by
Zoo
just recently right it was quite a
hearing the best evidence that this
small wash light group has are some of
the on-air clips from Fox News itself
most specifically from Sean Hannity all
right so that's the point I mean with
this hearing the living hell out of
people and I I see it again as like oh
let's bludgeon Trump with this Nuka hoax
tonight I can report the sky is
absolutely falling we are all doomed the
end is near the apocalypse is imminent
and you're going to all die all of you
in the next 48 hours and it's all
president Trump's fault or at least
that's what the media mob and the
Democratic extreme radical socialist
party would like you to think they are
now sadly politicizing and actually
weaponizing and infectious disease what
is basically just the latest effort to
bludgeon President Trump and joining us
now to talk about this case as David
McCraw deputy general counsel for The
New York Times and the papers lead
newsroom lawyer and Aidan McLaughlin who
is the editor in chief of media before
we get to you let me play for both of
you some of the arguments were made in
court last week in this zoom hearing
starting with Katherine Clark on behalf
of the wash light watchdog group it
causes a threat to the public health
because people rely on that information
and act accordingly underlying all of
that is an element and of reliability
authenticity and accurately yes and when
it comes to public health the rules are
different and that you can't lie about
there is no question that many of the
Fox News personalities are paid to
express their opinions and I'll have an
issue with that they certainly have that
right to do so under whatever their
contract is and whatever the
relationship and arrangement is between
Fox and AT&T and Comcast in spectrum but
when they start talking about falsehoods
that threaten the public health that is
simply not protected speech and it is
appropriately restrained and I'm not
trying to suggest that you should throw
prior restraint on its head here your
honor but this is again a very narrow
issue
is coded 19 a hoax it is certainly not
the lawyer for Fox News Michael Garvin
said this was nothing less than a full
frontal assault on the First Amendment
and here's how he put it in his argument
there's a great difference between
regulating conduct and regulating speech
the principle underlying the First
Amendment is that government cannot
prescribe what is orthodox having a
false statement of fact out there the
plurality and the dissent said is
actually helpful in finding the truth
because think about it this way if if
the court were able in any conceivable
circumstance to say that someone's
opinion about mass or the flu was false
that's only because there's an absolute
consensus on the other side well in a
circumstance like ours where you can't
read a newspaper or watch a TV without
having the consensus view put on you
then the best way to expose falsity is
to allow all all statements to flourish
and expose the false
whereat as if a court where the
government was to engage in prior
restraint and exclude those allegedly
false factual statements from the
marketplace of ideas then that would not
allow the truth to emerge that is of
course particularly true in a
circumstance like this where the notion
that there is some infallible truth
about the coronavirus that a single
court can dictate for the entire nation
is utterly elusive so the notion that a
court could step in and freeze this is
the only truth that can be put forth
from the marketplace of ideas would have
an extraordinarily detrimental effect
actually in effect and of course you not
only have to police understands of the
risk of the virus but overstate David
McCraw let me start with you Fox News
argues it should enjoy the same first
and then protection for its anchors and
hosts and their opinions as does the New
York Times and other print publications
would you agree with that I do agree
with that Brian thank you for having me
there's no question that truth is
important there's no question we should
do something about falsity the question
is
is what we do about it and going to
court is not the right answer I think
that this is a classic case where we
should be covering fox just like fox
covers the New York Times the publish me
speaking out on Twitter and elsewhere
the answer really lies with the public
to sort through what's true and what's
false and respond to falsity with a full
voice so no other consequence for
statements that appear to be quite false
that's exactly right
and it's one of the hard things I think
we all struggle with for those of us who
believe in the First Amendment the
Supreme Court addressed this case or
they addressed this issue in the United
States versus Alvarez a few years ago
and in that opinion the court said do we
really need the government to be a
Ministry of Truth once you frame it like
that you understand that the issue here
is the power of the government whether
that's writing laws that will restrict
the press courts applying those laws
those are the kind of things that begin
to create a problem and it actually cuts
against free expression in the end and I
think it cuts against free expression it
cuts against the truth we're facing this
kind of pressure in Russia we're facing
this kind of pressure in Egypt where
they have fake news laws and they want
to take on the New York Times The
Washington Post The Guardian and the
other international press that's just
not a path we should go down an eight
o'clock and let me ask you this even
though there's a strong First Amendment
protection for Fox News the network
seems to be taking this quite seriously
sure I mean I think the network's should
take any lawsuit like this seriously I
don't think that there's an assumption
within the network that this is going to
be a lawsuit that's going to cause them
much trouble you know despite I if you
remember a couple weeks ago Gabriel
Sherman at Vanity Fair was reporting
that within the network there were fears
that there early coverage of the corona
virus would cause legal trouble down the
road the people that I spoke to with
inside the network we're not taking that
particularly seriously you know the
sorts of lawsuits that that would cause
problems for a media organization from
media to Fox News would be sort of a
defamation
lawsuit this where a essentially an
organization is trying to determine
what's factual what's opinion what's
news what's what falls into sort of
approved opinions that Sean Hannity can
voice on his cable news show doesn't
seem like something that a lawyer in
Washington and a judge in Washington
should be outlining for a network like
Fox News so I think for when it comes to
criticism of the type of coverage that
Fox News puts on its airwaves I think
it's much better for media critics and
people on social media to to challenge
what's said on the airwaves at Fox News
as opposed to a court and daven the crop
question for you from Rhonda Schwartz
Rhonda in their lawsuit this small group
says that they have members who are
susceptible to falling ill to the virus
and one member who's indeed already ill
they're trying to make the point doesn't
the public health concern outweigh the
freedom of speech arguments what do you
say about that speech is a powerful
powerful tool journalism is powerful and
no doubt just as it can uplift it can
harm but I don't think we can react to
those particular kinds of harm by saying
let's change our whole system this is a
time for speaking out about the coverage
that wash light or any other group
thinks is wrong and having that public
debate I know that the the plaintiff
here is truly well motivated concerned
about public health concerned about
truth but again going to court doesn't
seem like the right answer the benefit I
think that society will get from this
the fact that they have raised these
issues and people are talking about it
that's not the same as being in favor of
having a court decide that it's going to
police a news organization and decide
what it can say in what can't say an
Eden Sean Hannity has said he never
called it a hoax although on that clip
but Thursday he caught this hoax what I
was talking about seem to be folks have
they at all changed their tune because
of this lawsuit and other
criticism of their coverage and their
opinions sure so it's Sean Hannity's
contention that from the beginning of
his coverage of this is when he's
referring to a hoax he means that the
sort of media coverage obsessive media
coverage of the corona virus pandemic is
a hoax that's being drummed up to
bludgeon President Donald Trump and you
saw that in the early days of Fox News's
coverage of this pandemic there was a
lot of time spent rejecting calls to
shut down the economy and also coverage
of the death toll as numbers were rising
in the United States because that was
seen as an effort to try and hurt for
them Donald Trump's popularity
eventually they got a lot of criticism
for that particularly in January and
February their coverage downplaying the
corona virus it was met with a pretty
strong wave of criticism and their tune
did change it changed I'd say before
President Donald Trump's tune did you
know you look in in late March president
Trump was still comparing the current
virus to the flu and Fox News a few
weeks before had sent everyone home to
certainly distance from home and had
shut down their headquarters so the Fox
News did change its coverage I would say
was probably more in response that
heated criticism that they were getting
than the threat of this wash light
lawsuit and Fox News did take a number
of steps to try and convey that they
were taking this seriously
they fired Trish Regan who is a Fox
Business host who made some comments
that were very similar to Sean Hannity's
comment she of course is a lesser-known
cable news host and and had much lower
ratings so I think they were a little
bit more comfortable reprimanding her
for those comments
and they also punished two pundits that
were on the Fox Nation streaming
platform diamond and silk who floated a
bunch of coronavirus conspiracy theories
so there have been some sporadic efforts
by management to try and keep the
criticism at bay and also the top hosts
on on Fox News have sort of changed the
way that they're covering this they cast
it less as a hoax now at least the
coverage of it and are looking more
towards sort of we
putting up the country and trying to
focus more on the economy than the
pandemic itself and David McCraw as you
know all too well the Trump
administration in the campaign has not
been hesitant to sue news organizations
itself that's right there has been three
now I guess for suits brought by the
Trump campaign the campaign entity
against news organizations and again
that's why I see this as of a piece this
kind of suit where people are tempted to
go into court to try to resolve their
there are there problems with the media
what they disagree with we were sued
during the last election by a trump
supporter who said we were part of a
racketeering conspiracy that forced him
to have to contribute more to Donald
Trump's campaign because of our coverage
I'm thankful to say the courts threw
that out that was the right outcome so
we're gonna see a lot more of this sort
of action in courts if this ruling were
to go in favor of the wash light group
III fear that it opens a door if that's
the case now obviously a trial court
decision is not in Washington's not
likely presidential scene as
presidential as elsewhere but if it were
firm that would happen it's just you
when I understand wash light trying to
say that hey I'm just talking about
public health and probably costs
important but if you look at what's
going on in this country it's almost
impossible to sort out the public health
component of the pandemic from its
economic cultural ramifications where do
you draw the line when are you talking
about
the effect of the shutdown versus public
health or the effect on people's mental
health rather than physical health all
of these things are are part of a piece
and I just don't think that's a line
that can be drawn no matter how
well-intentioned the plaintiffs may be
all right well I really expected later
this week according to Judge Brian
McDonald Dave lacrosse in the New York
Times thank you so much for joining us
and you to aid mcLaughlin from the
meteorite part of the law and crime
family thanks both of you for being here
- thanks Brian thanks Rhonda thank
yep coming up who's watching the White
House henhouse with for Inspector
General's fired and your questions about
color 19 in the law your rights your job
your marriage and your divorce when we
come back you're watching the long crime
trial Network continuing now our report
in the midst of this pandemic President
Trump has decided to fire four
inspectors general for key departments
in his administration the officials who
are supposed to look out for wrongdoing
and the misuse of money President Trump
may be legally allowed to do that but
there are questions now about who will
be watching the henhouse at the White
House during this to get a better
understanding of that I talked with
Clark Kent Ervin a Republican and a
former inspector general himself who
aggravated his bosses in the bush
administration Clark Kent Ervin thank
you so much for joining us you are an
inspector general at the Department of
Homeland Security during the Bush
administration and they essentially got
rid of you didn't they
well I was actually never confirmed as
inspector general at the Department of
Homeland Security President Bush gave me
a recess appointment the recess
appointment expired and there's no
question but that there were a number of
hard-hitting reports that I issued as
DHS inspector general and ultimately I
antagonize the administration as a
result of that I recall covering your
efforts back then and you were very
critical of any of these steps being
taken to guarantee homeland security and
they didn't like them at all so what's
the impact you think now with the
president Trump getting rid of at least
four inspectors general well there's no
question Brian but this is having a
chilling effect no doubt on the
inspectors general who remain in it
likely will have a chilling effect also
on those who might contemplate becoming
inspectors channel inspectors general
are a unique institution within
government they are inside an agency but
they're in inside an administration but
they're supposed to be independent of
that agents
independent of the administration of
course typically when inspectors general
appointed by a president they share the
political affiliation the partisan
affiliation the ideological positioning
of the president but once they take that
oath of office and assume the job
they're supposed to check their
political and partisan affiliations at
the door and they're supposed to
undertake such audits and investigations
as they think they should and they're
supposed to come to the conclusions that
the facts lead them to even if those
conclusions are contrary to the
political interests of the
administration so these these firings
these demotions so many of them coming
in such quick succession and it being so
clear what the purpose is it surely will
dissuade inspectors general from as I
say undertaking audits and
investigations that are likely to
displease the agency and the
administration the White House says the
president has the absolute right to get
rid of any inspector general he wants
and here's how the Secretary of State my
crime failed but the president has the
unilateral right to choose who he wants
to be his Inspector General at every
agency in the federal government their
presidential confirmed positions and
those persons just like all of us serve
at the pleasure of the President of the
United States in this case I recommended
to the president that's Steve linic be
terminated frankly should have done it
some time ago so do you agree with that
Clark well I agree with this the
presidents have the right to the to
nominate inspectors general and they
have the legal right to fire them but
just because one has the legal authority
to do that doesn't mean that that should
be done as you know there is a
particular provision in the inspector
general Act of 2008 that requires the
President to give Congress 30 days
notice before finding inspectors general
one and two to give reasons for that
firing and that is intended to be a
limitation frankly on the president's
removal power and it's intended to give
presidents pause before doing so one the
30-day period and two it's intended to
require them to justify those firings
or for a good reason so the statute does
not contemplate that inspectors general
are like every other political appointee
that serves at the pleasure of the
president unless the Inspector General
has done something wrong unless the
Inspector General has failed to do his
or her job inspector general are not
intended to be fired and that's why
there have been effort to reform the
inspector general act further to make it
clear that there should be only for
cause removal there is such a provision
in this new heroes Act that was
introduced in the house a week ago or so
a number of members of Congress and both
parties are supportive of that so we'll
see if if anything comes of that and and
I should say in that regard that if
anything positive comes from this in
addition to that for-cause removal
provision I just mentioned I hope it
will shine a spotlight on just what
inspectors general will do who they are
and why they're critical to this
accountable system of government that
our framers so wisely set up you've now
seen these four inspectors general who
are either deputies or full inspector
general removed from their jobs and
these are really important agencies and
departments over which they saw was
going on lots of money being spent in
these agencies and no longer a appears
to be an independent Inspector General
absolutely and further you know there's
always a lot of money spent in
government needless to say but we are in
the context of course of a pandemic
unprecedented amounts of money trillions
of dollars have been injected into the
economy and they've been inject into the
economy quickly so that means that there
are massive opportunities commensurate
with the amount of money we're talking
about massive opportunities for waste
fraud mismanagement and abuse and if
there's ever been a time when it's
critical to have independent and
aggressive watchdogs overseeing how that
money is spent making sure that the
applicable laws and regulations are
being complied with making sure that
there's no conflict of interest in the
disbursement and use of that money it's
it's never been more critical that it is
now I look back at the example of
sigtarp the special inspector general
that was set up
decade ago in the aftermath the great
recession that that particular watchdog
is still going all these many years
later there was no cutoff on the tongue
of that Inspector General and there have
been hundreds of convictions as a result
of this and a lot of money recovered
it's been a critical institution to hold
the government accountable for the
massive spending a decade ago it's even
more important as I say given the amount
of money at issue here for there to be
inspectors general overseeing this let
me ask you this would you today take an
appointment from this administration to
be an inspector general in the Trump
administration well that's a good
question Brian I'm an unusual person in
that political pressure doesn't affect
me so I probably would actually but the
issue is with the would most people do
that with the average person do that and
I do think that as I say that it's
unlikely in this climate that there will
be people who are willing to step
forward and step into these very very
sensitive positions one thing I will
note is that over the course of the
decades there has been commendably
bipartisan support for the institution
of inspectors general senator Grassley
has been a longtime champion of the
inspector general community when I was
the inspector general at the State
Department homeland security department
I worked very closely with him more
closely than any other member of
Congress in the House or Senate Democrat
a Republican and I would note that
Senator Grassley senator Portman sander
Langford recently sent a letter to the
administration urging the White House to
cooperate with inspectors general and to
let them do their jobs in other
Republican senators senator Romney
senator Collins have likewise support
for the inspector general community and
concern about what's gone going on
recently so that I hope this will
galvanize a bipartisan consensus in
support of shoring up the institution of
inspectors general so that they can
perform this critical watchdog function
at this critical time in our country's
history all right Clark Kent
and thank you so much for joining us we
appreciate it very much thank you so
much Brian up next your questions about
Cove at 19 and the law your love your
marriage your divorce you're watching
the long crime trial Network when the
case first broke Shannon and CeCe and
Bella were simply missing like I have no
inclination to where they're at right
now something in your gut was telling
you that he had something to do with it
Chris Watts thought that he could go to
the police department knowing the fact
that he killed his family through a
polygraph test continuing now with your
questions about Cove at 19 and the law
Rhonda Schwartz we're getting lots of
questions about love and marriage that's
right Brian it's May it's the
traditional wedding season May and June
and everybody is wondering about the
events that they had put on hold and
what's gonna happen and we're seeing
lots of creative solutions of the fact
that weddings can't be held with large
crowds here are some of what we saw
around the country this week a lot of
spring and summer weddings have been
postponed or canceled because of kovat
19 small wedding businesses are
maneuvering to find ways to keep love
alive
Megan and Sue lob chose their fairytale
venue Miller's castle in Connecticut
after a virtual tour we had a FaceTime
phone call my fiance and I we walked
through every piece of the venue and to
help you say yes to the dress companies
including beholdin bride side and Daniel
Franco will ship wedding gown samples
for you to try on and for anyone who
doesn't want to wait you can say a
socially distance I do
the Queens couple married by their
councilmen last month or you can bring
your entire family together virtually
what we do is we take the stress out of
it the company is now one of a few
across the country that helps couples
with every step of virtual wedding
planning modern REBOL deals with
everything from digital invitations
virtual video keepsakes and DJs
contactless deliveries of wedding must
like cake and flowers day of
coordination and even virtual rehearsal
dinners a celebration box Tara Federico
what scheme events fills them with
confetti and a USB that includes the
wedding ceremony in speeches anything
that really represents at your wedding
that you've been planning for months for
family and friends who can no longer
attend the wedding but can celebrate
from afar so this is a gift to say we
love you we want to include you and
we're joined now by Heidi Harris from
Aronson Meyer ski-in Sloane and Steve
Hyman from the firm of McLaughlin Stern
and Heidi let me start with you a
question for one of our viewers my son
is getting married are supposed to get
married at the end of August in
Minnesota the venue is expecting him to
comply with the contract if the governor
won't allow the wedding's with more than
200 guests what are our options well I
I'm sorry to say that you're a bit of a
pickle if you can't have that kind of a
crowd you're gonna have to limit the
number of people that are able to attend
the event
everybody's obviously got to comply with
the federal guidelines regarding koban
19 and you you may have to you know be
creative and potentially have you know
computer screens or something thinking
of adding it would be surprising to me
though that a venue would not you know
offer a an alternate date in the future
so that they can fill the venue they can
have it you know keep their reputation
but you're gonna have to find some
creative way to do it if that's what
you're intending on doing it looks like
it in Steve Hyman it raises a larger
question of our rights during this
pandemic how we're rights do we give up
to make sure everyone's health is
protected you've seen some of the
stories about whether religion is an
essential gathering whether they're
peaceful protests sort of central
gathering
this is a real issue isn't it as we sort
of go to the slow reopening of the
country right I mean you you are now
faced with issues of how you lived your
life and protect your rights
in an area where health is the primary
factor that's driving what issues are
taking place I mean I think that in the
end you're going to have to concede that
health is going to drive the issue but
if you are permitting groups to appear
for religion then you have to do it for
First Amendment activities such as
protest how that fits in with a wedding
though is a different issue that's a
real contract issue that in fact my firm
is involved in one right now how that's
going to play out I'm not sure under the
contract
whether it's what's called force majeure
or whether there are some issues if the
facility can provide for the number of
people you they've agreed to take then I
think they have to put the date off at
the very least if not refund the money
all right
the Heidi Harris a question for you from
Rhonda Schwarz Rhonda Heidi we saw all
the creative ways people are trying to
move forward with weddings with the
courts closed what if you want to file
for divorce is it possible to go forward
with that
what's that situation like at the moment
today you can do it last week you
couldn't the courts have just opened
this week to allow for the filing of new
matters including divorces I don't know
if I should say I'm happy to say that
you can get a divorce now but you can
this was put on hold for a bit of time
it did raise a couple of questions from
a legal standpoint about the potential
mischief that one party could do against
another one while the person was not
found to have the ability to to file an
action and obtain these automatic orders
that we have that keeps certain assets
place but now you can yes it's all being
done electronically however there aren't
any court appearances there is no more
personal filings but yes it can move
ahead now and Steve Hyman you've seen
some of the protests going on people
want the country reopened who determines
what is essential and is there a
challenge if you don't have your act
included in the essential acts well I
mean that's the fundamental question
what is essential I mean the standards
are going to be different if it's a
constitutional nature as compared to a
regular business nature how that is
going to be determined by the courts
ultimately we don't know but at least it
essential I mean in in Vermont where I
am right now liquor stores are essential
other businesses we're not how do you
make the distinction as to what's
essential if it comes though to a
fundamental rights such as the right to
tray or the right to protest then you
have a constitutional dimension that is
has to be measured against that of the
health issue and certainly if you permit
people to line up to buy groceries
saying they have to be six feet apart
but they can do it or line up even to go
into a store for liquor then you have to
I think permit the First Amendment
rights both from a prayer point of view
and a protest point of view you have to
at least give the opportunity with maybe
limiting the number of people and having
the social distance in place Heidi
another question for you
if bowling alleys and tattoo parlors are
considered essential shouldn't weddings
also be called essential that's an
interesting question
I'm surprised that tattoos and bowling
alleys are considered essential I would
think that a wedding might be a little
bit more essential or a number of
reasons and promotes public policy of
you know people getting married and
having families and it's a it's a funny
question but I I can't explain I'm sorry
also that a Brian you could add how do
you measure essential with a funeral as
compared to a wedding I mean it brings
up the same issue of definition and
either think of something that is of a
serious fundamental thing back and that
really can't be put off in the same way
that a wedding might be right and Heidi
what is the principle question you're
getting from your clients about areas of
marriage and divorce well a lot of
people who are currently in the midst of
their divorces or have finished up their
cases have signed their agreements will
always want to know that in fact people
want to know this as soon as they come
in through the door how long is it going
to take and then can I get my judgment
and unfortunately it has also just been
announced that it is very unlikely that
any divorces are going to be finally
granted judgment stamp end-of-summer
or possibly even end of year you know
it's there they're saying that if
usually it takes about two months once
the papers are signed for you to get
your judgment it's going to take
significantly longer now and the judges
are also warning don't try to claim that
there is an emergency here that you got
to get your divorce signed immediately
it's really not going to work very well
all right we're gonna continue with more
of your questions after a break
including questions about all those
gatherings are they the right thing to
do are they putting other people's
health at risk who has the rights in
this case we'll get to those questions
after a break you're watching the long
crime trial Network
when the case first broke shenana and
CeCe and Bella were simply missing like
I have no inclination to where they're
at right now something in your gut was
telling you that he had something to do
with it
Chris Watts thought that he could go to
the police department knowing the fact
that he killed his family breeze through
a polygraph test we continue now with
your questions about Cove at 19 and the
law well as more and more people have
fewer fears and parts of the country
about Cova 19 and the warm weather
starts to push in we're seeing more and
more cases of people pushing back
against limits on social gatherings
often leading to confrontations and
arrests let's flock to Coney Island
today anyway a lot of masks but not a
whole lot of social distance New Yorkers
flocked to City beaches and parks by the
thousands in Central Park access to the
Sheep Meadow Limited at Hudson River
Park where overcrowding is known to be
an issue cops on patrol giving up mass
those laying out reminded by signs that
social distancing is a must
multiple NYPD officers who were caught
on tape over the weekend violently
scuffling with a man and later
handcuffing him the video starts with a
commotion as officers arrested a couple
yesterday on 9th Street and Avenue D in
the East Village suddenly one of the
officers breaks away from that arrest
and walks up to a bystander with his
taser drawn swearing and telling him to
move back
the officer tackles him and can be seen
slapping and punching him over and over
as his on the ground
rested after she got upset when she was
instructed to wear a face mask police
say the 22 year old was with her young
child at the Atlantic Avenue subway
station when cops asked her to put on
her mask
they say she refused and responded with
profanity and so let's go back now to
hide the air
Steve Hyman Steve I'm in the cases of
arrest like that are they going to hold
up in court once this pandemic starts to
recede yeah I think they will
necessitate I mean these are real tough
tough issues Supreme Court has said you
could put somebody in isolation for you
know smallpox yellow fever you can
require a vaccination the requirement of
wearing a mask is pretty reasonable
compared to putting somebody into an
isolation tent as they did with kaci
Hickox in the Ebola case so I think that
that can hold up if they're properly
implemented and fairly enforced the
problem of course is just the number of
people can overwhelm a system and then
you've got chaos which is what can
happen particularly when you have a
president that is taking the situation
that masks aren't really necessary so I
don't need one so why do you in Heidi
Harris let me ask you speaking of chaos
with so much closest now in force
because of the lockdown and the lack of
social gatherings are you seeing more
divorces or people patching things up
it's a good question I think everybody
originally thought you know the phones
are gonna be ringing off the hook
and then we saw some articles saying you
know people are gonna try and give it
another shot you know they're stuck
together as a family for the good of the
children for the good of themselves of
the marriage I think personally we're
gonna stay pretty level there may be a
surge now that we can start new actions
that may have been something that was
holding people up but I'm not sure you
know when you are all locked together
you really don't have that kind of
privacy where you can talk to your
lawyer by yourself it may not be exactly
the right time to get started but I
think for sure we're going to keep
things level if not see some bit of an
increase and just repeat you're saying
the courts are not open again to at
least in New York except divorce actions
yes yes for a while
were only accepting motions and
conferences and pending cases you're now
allowed to start and initiate a new
proceeding Steve Hyman a question for
you from Rhonda Schwarz Rhonda we saw a
lot of public gatherings over this
weekend of all kinds and one of the big
issues also was religious services
what does Religious Freedom give you the
right to gather together in church with
without mass work where did this where
does that stand now well you you have
it's the same as protest it's a First
Amendment right so it has to be
respected the problem is the gathering
together with people so there's a
balance of the health which is also a
fundamental issue versus the church
right yeah I think that ultimately
they're going to have to come up with a
situation where people have a right if
they have a right to congregate at all
with certain numbers they're gonna have
a right to congregate for church
services but they'll have to one either
wear masks and maintain social distance
there have been court proceedings
already that have found that the right
for religion is a fundamental right and
it overruled I believe in Kansas the
judges the governor's order banning
complete ban on religious services and
Steve what makes sense to you in terms
of that what really makes sense here you
have liberals Democrats the mayor de
Blasio and Governor Cuomo and they don't
include in their essential gatherings
peaceful protest versus well they Cuomo
actually changed that the Civil
Liberties Union had a case and a good
friend of mine Norman Siegel had a case
in which there were the police were
permitting people lining up to stores
and everything
but if you lined up for a protest you
got a summons and threatened with arrest
Governor Cuomo changed that order so it
does respect now the right to protest as
long as it's limited in number and as
long as their social distancing and I
assume wearing a mask the Heidi Harris
let me get back to you about this
question of what's going on in the homes
and all togetherness whether it's a
desire or not are you also seeing any
cases of violence domestic violence I've
been fortunate that none of my cases
have personally been been involved
involved any of that but yes there have
to be I know that there was a recent
clip that that you've had shown on an
earlier episode of the show where it
clearly makes sense that if there is
that kind of a dynamic between a
survivor and an abuser that being in
close quarters especially by the way if
they're in a small apartment in the city
or know New York City Queens Brooklyn
Staten Island and they really don't have
the ability to move around very much and
get out there's definitely a potential
for heightened acrimony and possibly
violence absolutely yes I mean people
can still call the police obviously
essential actions have always included
matters involving domestic violence and
orders of protection I can't imagine
that it hasn't increased to some extent
and as you say there's a really a lack
of privacy when families are all
together very quickly you've got 30
seconds here but your best advise to
people who are going through some tough
times in their marriage I think that if
you can find some space to have a little
bit of alone time even if it involves
walking around the block you know
properly protected or or just doing
something that can clear your head some
activity that can get you away and not
always with the same people all the time
I think that does an awful lot to sort
of diffuse emotions and and we just have
to stick this out there's really no no
great alternative
unfortunately absolutely people have
isolation highly Harris thank you so
much
yep absolutely Heidi Harris thank you so
much for joining us Steve Hyman also
thank you so much and Rhonda Schwartz as
always good to have you on the program
thanks to all of you for watching today
Jessie Webber's here tomorrow we're back
Thursday and thanks to the law on crime
T that gets us on the air and off the
air
[Music]
you